whenever I show film from my six-month
expedition on the space station I have
to qualify some of the scenes and I'll
say things like like I have one of the
space station like this where the earth
is moving below at the station this
shuttle took it and I'll say I know this
looks like animation but it's actually
really real and so when I met Alfonso
Cuaron he said you know I can't believe
that you have been to space and I said
to him well after seeing gravity I can't
believe that you haven't and you know
I'm actually not making a joke I just
think it's I think it's a wonderful film
and we're here tonight to meet some of
the people who created a movie that
brought all of us to space and in my job
as an astronaut that's one of the things
that's really hard about it is that I
get to go but my family doesn't get to
go my friends don't get to go but
gravity brought them to the place with
it meant so much to me
so mouth both Alfonso and I are driven
to take people on journeys to places
that they can't go by themselves and I
think the visual experience is a really
important part of making that happen
I've described my spaceflight to folks
in great detail before and I think they
think they understand all about it I
mean I'll sit there at lunch and we'll
talk about things and I'll describe
things and then I show the videos and
they look at me and they go oh eat you
would there I became connected with the
gravity movie while I was living on the
space station my brother met Sandra
Bullock's brother-in-law and they put us
together how great is that so during our
phone conversations between Earth and
space Sandra and I focused really on two
things the first one was how to move I
tried to share what it felt like to get
up in the morning and fly you know I'd
open the door of my cabin I would fly
through the lab I would hook right
through the node do all those things
that people do in the morning and I
would fly as Peter Pan would say
straight on till morning I wanted her to
understand that you could
of yourself anywhere with the lightest
touch of a finger and in fact you could
take a single hair from your head and
you can stretch it between two hands
like this and you could use it to push
off of any kind of corner or thing and
that would move you all the way across
the space station that's how little
force it takes the second thing that we
focused on was how it felt to live in
space when everyone that you knew and
loved was very far away and despite our
amazing technology here in this earth
we're still people and I have a husband
and a son who was 10 at the time as a
grown stepson and it was very hard to
leave them behind
I mean exploring the universe means real
people doing hard things and those
people have families they have friends
they have emotions and I think in
gravity they helped us get to know Ryan
stone and by the end of the movie we all
really wanted her to find a reason to
live and a reason to come home so it's a
very very human thing to take these big
steps it was significant to me that
gravity had a female hero I think it's
invaluable for the next generations to
see themselves in tough resilient
characters like Ryan stone the makers of
gravity sent a powerful message and it
is so important that girls can be and
need to be part of the technological
solutions for our planet can you imagine
the idea of millions of girls around the
planet thinking that they could do
anything it's awesome
it's ironic to me that the world of
movies in the world of space exploration
share the same imperatives to launch
live in orbit around our planet and come
home safely or to make a movie that
takes people from their seats in a
theater into orbit around the earth well
it requires technology and innovation at
their highest levels but the ultimate
result is to further the human
experience and with gravity I think that
you've shared not just a view of this
beautiful planet but what it felt like
to have that view both movies and actual
exploration asked us to suspend our
disbelief and I think that's ok today
we're learning to leave our planet at
NASA
the newest u.s. capsule is slated for
its first unmanned flight later this
year that's very soon in our book and in
parallel we're developing the
technologies that we still need in order
to travel to Mars at some point in our
future some of our children are going to
call another planet home and I can look
you in the eye and I can promise you
that the experiments that we are doing
on your space station are going to
change your lives in terms of science
human physiology and technology and
they're going to continue to change the
very nature of the way that we live our
lives on this and other planets you in
Hollywood who create movies films and
music you'll continue to inspire the
next generations and so will we at NASA
our children will see themselves in your
movies and shows and they're also gonna
see themselves in our real life space
dramas and our daily work in a place
where failure isn't an option but flying
from place to place is a reality an
exploration is unstoppable NASA and my
space station crew salute the makers of
gravity as fellow space travelers we
thank them for helping the world to
visualize our mission and for showing
everyone that there are explorers among
us